Apple's iPhone event is just days away
where we're gonna see the full iPhone 14
lineup and the new Apple watch but we
just got a bombshell leak that changes
everything about the iPhone 14 Pro's
design and we were not expecting this at
all but it actually makes sense with
some new leaks that came out explaining
why Apple made this decision so let me
show you guys check this out we just got
the rumor on Wednesday saying that the
iPhone 14 pro display cutouts could
appear as a single wide pill shape when
turned on look at that right there in
the image a single wide pill shape yes
not the old version with the Dual
cutouts with one being circular and the
other being pill-shaped which we all got
used to and we all expected no it's
getting completely changed to this wide
pill and that's exactly what we can see
right here from a Chinese weibo post
that's what we got used to that is what
we are getting which really looks weird
dude right now but I think we're all
going to get used to it and the crazy
thing is strip Apple Pro on Twitter was
the first one to show off that dual cut
out leak way long ago and you can see
right here he said that he doesn't think
the full pill of the iPhone 14 pro is
happening all the leaks and rumors Point
towards the pill plus whole design we
even have a real image of the glass
panel now that was back on August 30th
and he came back the next day saying
that no it's not going to be a big pill
which it looks like at that moment he
was actually wrong because on Wednesday
we got an exclusive Mac Rumors Forum
post by an anonymous user saying that
his Apple engineer Buddy says that it's
going to be hidden via software the pill
plus hole is going to be hidden and it's
going to look like an elongated pill
shape as you can see right here boom and
making it even better Mark German the
most reliable Apple leaker came out and
said that yes indeed it will look like
one wide pill as you can see in this
tweet right here so of course because of
that I asked renders by Shailesh which
makes a lot of rendez for us to update
them to show what it's going to look
like in real life with this bronze color
and this new dark blue-ish color and as
you can see it actually looks really
really nice it feels a bit weird but I
think we're gonna love it over time so
definitely follow renders by Celeste on
Twitter and just to give you an example
of what it could look like in your hands
the Apple Hub posted this render which
actually it looks pretty sick now that
you're looking at it in somebody's hand
now I know what a lot of you guys are
gonna say why would Apple make the whole
dual punch cut out in the first place
like this Mac Rumors Forum user Torx who
said why not just cut out a pill instead
of disabling pixels inside of that
little section that's going to end up
being black now I had that question as
well and it looks like the Lee Acres
actually revealed it according to a
source from nine to five Mac as you can
see the Apple Hub reposted it apple is
going to be relocating the Privacy
indicators Into the Dead Space inside
the pill shaped cutout on the iPhone 14
pro and they're also working on a
redesigned camera app so you can see
right here the little indicators that
you have when you're recording your
screen or something's recording the
microphone or the camera it's going to
be moved on the inside which makes total
sense for apple to make use of that
space instead of the current method
where they kind of have it up in the
corner and it's kind of hard to see this
is going to be easy to see specifically
because of this new leak that said that
the Privacy indicators in the pill shade
cutout are going to be brighter than the
rest of the display similar to the Mac
camera LED and the source actually said
that it's going to be much brighter than
the rest of the display with them using
some sort of HDR content to make it look
very very bright to make sure that even
if you're outside with maximum
brightness you're still going to see
those indicators which is going to help
for privacy and I actually tweeted about
this saying that okay now this makes
sense because if on the actual glass
panel they blacked out the section in
between both cutouts then you wouldn't
be able to see those indicators so they
had to leave it open like you can see in
this display panel leak where you do
have both of these cutouts with that
space open they had to do that because
if they just fully painted it black
obviously those indicators wouldn't be
visible so what if this was Apple's
master plan the entire time and then
nobody figured it out until now and the
nice thing about this leak is that we
did get confirmation from shrimp Apple
Pro that yes he was a little bit wrong
but kind of not because they can just
turn off that section in software and
technically on the hardware itself it's
still a pill plus haul so he's kind of
admitting that yes it is going to be
done using software and he agrees with
with the elongated pill-shaped cutout
and now on top of that let's finish off
with a couple of more rumors we got
another one saying that once again apple
is going to be increasing the storage to
256 gigs on the Pro Models which we were
going back and forth back and forth and
now we're getting more saying it's 256
so I'm honestly not sure what to expect
in terms of that but somebody on the Mac
Rumors Forum made a good point con tacos
he said that let's not forget the
debacle of prores being only available
on devices 256 gigs and up so of course
with the 8K video camera coming it might
actually make sense for Apple to start
with 256 so everybody has access to that
feature without any limitations so I'm
really hoping for that now let's get
into the next section that I want to
talk about and that is the new regular
iPhone 14 model which we thought was
going to be the 14 Max for the longest
time it's basically just the 14 with a a
larger display and larger battery now
we're getting some rumors that it's
going to be the plus and they started
with Tommy Boy on Twitter when he posted
this tweet where he zoomed in and this
says iPhone 14 plus on what looks to be
an official case on a display so he kept
looking into it and he kept finding more
evidence that hey look here's another
case iPhone 14 plus here's more cases
from other case makers where it says 14
plus so apparently the case makers were
informed recently that it's not going to
be 14 Max whoever said that they wanted
to make sure that they're going to be
saying 14 plus and he keeps showing more
and more 14 plus cases from different
vendors as you can see here ESR gear
more vendors saying 14 plus so it's
looking more and more like this is gonna
happen and then of course nine to five
Mac did come out with some additional
evidence where they confirmed with their
own separate sources that yes it's going
to be iPhone 14 plus and not Max now
let's try to make some sense of that
well first of all Apple has been using
the max branding for kind of their best
of the best products of course they have
their iPhone 14 pro Max which is their
largest but also their best but the real
interesting piece of info is that they
have their Mac lineup like this 16 inch
MacBook Pro where they have the M1 Pro
and M1 Max chips so in this case Max is
meant to be like the best of the best
the most powerful and in that case maybe
Apple doesn't want to Brand the regular
iPhone 14 as the max because then you'll
think that you're getting the best of
the best when you really you're not so
maybe it makes sense to just make it the
14 plus because you're getting the
regular 14 all the same features it's
just plus sized but you're not getting
all the max best of the best features
which you can only get on the highest
end I phone 14 pro Max and I think that
actually makes sense from a marketing
perspective for Apple now if you
disagree with me let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe because the Apple event is
going to be amazing in just a couple of
days I am so excited and we're going to
cover a bunch of stuff so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]